the Joe Rogan experience to the end of
the book there is a murderer in there
that I think the Manson family committed
that was covered up by the law
enforcement cuz it screwed up it would
have screwed up the prosecution
I want that looked into there's also at
the end of the book there are these text
watts and audio tapes that I found out
about in 2008 when Watson turned himself
in when he found he was alerted and in
Texas he was at his parents house they
called the police called the local
sheriff who was Texas cousin and his
parents and said he's wanted for
questioning in these unsolved tape
murders and this was November 29th
nobody had been identified publicly as
suspects the police were just starting
to figure out that these people had
killed their victims so - LAPD flew down
to Texas
Watson was brought into the station
questioned by the LAPD put under arrest
they had to extradite him so that the
sheriff their Texas cousin put him in a
Cell the family called up a lawyer Bill
Boyd who had actually represented Tex on
a college case when he stole a
typewriter from a college and a prank
Bill Boyd told me in an interview in
2008 that that day he had Tex tell him
the whole story or Charles as he called
him about how he met Manson why the
murders were committed how they happened
he said he spoke to me for 20 hours and
he goes I've got all those audio tapes
in a safe in my office he told me this
in 2008 he said he also described other
murders that the family had committed
that hadn't been connected to them
so right away when you know I'm in 2000
I'm working on it that long I thought
other murders that's important to me but
more important did he tell his attorney
why the murders really happened you know
why they picked those houses you know
this was the first account that was
recorded the next one was Susan Atkins
about a week later after she had gotten
her new attorney that the prosecution
planted they audio taped her telling her
version which became the official
version
so Watson's would predate that by a week
and when I found out that they were in
that safe and he's telling me this on
the phone I thought why he he can't play
that to me because that would violate
Watson's attorney-client privilege but I
thought I have to ask so I said is there
any chance mr. Boyd I could come down
and listen to those tapes and he said
that's when he realized he shouldn't
have told him he said oh well I I
couldn't do that without Charlie Charles
Watson Charles permission like oh he's
still in touch with me no so I write to
him every now and then he writes me he
didn't represent him at trial after he
was extradited and I said would you
please ask so that began three or four
months of me pestering him he would
never take the phone call and then
finally after four months I called up in
his secretary said oh I'm sorry mr.
Boies in China on business today and I
said well you have to tell him I'm not
gonna wait anymore I'm gonna write to
Charles and tell him what he told me I
go if there's other bodies I mean I
didn't let them know that I was more
interested in the motive story but I
said if there's and I was interested in
this too I go if there's other bodies or
victims out there who have never been on
connected or even we only know if the
remains were uncovered because there's a
lot of evidence that there might have
been people killed out in the desert and
buried there I go I need to know that
and she said okay I'll tell him my phone
rang like literally 30 seconds after I
hung it up and I had call her idea that
was from his Texas office goes this is
billboard you cannot call Charles and
tell him I told you that I said mr. Boyd
you haven't called me back for four
months it goes what I'm telling you now
you can't do that I go well are you
gonna you know get his permission he
goes yeah you just have to be patient I
go I can't wait anymore he says if you
do that and you tell him Alton I ever
telling you I said it's all on tape I
taped that call because you didn't have
permission to tape that call go yeah you
gave me permission at the beginning and
that's on tape - it goes god damn it you
journalists and he hung up on me you
journalists ya lumped in with all of
them you know he said my wife said
you're his wife is a TV
he was my wife so I know how you people
work I go you gave me permission it's on
the audiotape so he died six months
later on the treadmill oh my god
thinking about you and his his firm went
bankrupt and then it was until two or
three years later and it's all in there
the back story but I finally went to try
to get the tapes again and found out he
had died found out that the tapes were
in the possession of the trustee who was
you know waiting for the bankruptcy to
be of all resolved and it took me three
four months of back and forth and to try
to get them to release the tapes to me
and I made an argument for why they
weren't protected anymore again long
story short I was sharing information
with the deputy da in Los Angeles who I
thought was friendly he was until he
wasn't and he was handling all the
parole hearings of the Manson Family
gonna impact sukira the woman who was in
charge of the tapes the trustee said if
secure calls me and tells me that it's
okay for me to release them to you and
explains how it's not a violation I'll
do it I said Alaskan so I asked me said
absolutely I want to talk to her and I
said great a day later I get a call from
secure because you're not gonna believe
it she's releasing the tapes to us like
oh you he goes yeah yeah don't worry
I'll let you hear him when we get them
she asked I knew right then I had lost
any kind of control and sure enough
number one the trustee had to notify
Watson's new attorney Watson put up a
fight in court and it's in you can read
about in the other times I reported on
that for about a year for about a year
it went from the the local court to the
state Supreme Court where the judge
finally ruled that the LAPD should have
the tapes they sent two officers down to
get the tapes in 2013 they came back and
then nobody at the DA's office would
talk to me anymore
the promise that had been made that I
would be the first one to listen to them
reneged those tapes a million
journalists have made Freedom of
Information Act requests for them they
won't release them there
dot Leslie Manhattan's attorney wants
him he thinks it'll help her at her
parole hearings because he thinks
there's information on there to show
that she's been telling the truth all
these years he's gone to the state
Supreme Court through other courts they
blocked them down
it's 20 hours first account of how and
why these murders occurred and they're
not releasing them I think it's because
the truth is on there
[Applause]